peut-on réaliser une vidéo en ayant la
crève c'est la question à laquelle nous
allons répondre aujourd'hui avec la
personne de justin de france qui est moi
on va aussi parler de cinéma un peu
puisque c'est le titre de ce hors sujet
j'aime faire de leur sujet ça va partir
dans tous les sens ça va parler
principalement des films qui sont sortis
en 2018 et même exclusivement et
j'espère que ça sera intéressant j'ai eu
envie de faire cette vidéo parce que je
me suis rendu compte que j'avais vu
énormément de films en 2018
deux films sortis en 2018 et je me
disais que ça pourrait être intéressant
vous en parler puisque je regarde
beaucoup de films aux genres gens
regardent environ en moyenne un par jour
et donc je pense avoir une petite
connaissances cinématographiques que je
voulais mettre à profit même si le
propos de cette chaîne n'est pas de
parler de cinéma et ne le sera jamais
principalement énormément de chaîne qui
parle déjà très bien de cinéma mais là
j'avais envie d'en parler et je fais ce
que je veux
du coup cette année j'ai donc vu sans
trois films sortis en 2018
je les ai pas forcément tous vus au
cinéma puisque il y en a certains que je
me suis procuré par la suite et que j'ai
vu sur mon petit écran il y en a aussi
que j'ai vu plusieurs fois parce que je
suis un peu folle le début d'année par
exemple a été pas mal occupé en
visionnage de star wars 8 qui est sorti
en 2010 est mais qui était encore en
cinéma en 2018 et du coup j'étais
obligée d'y aller a eu un bi foua et
donc forcément j'ai moins vu de film en
début d'année puisque quand j'allais au
cinéma je n'avais d'yeux que pour un
seul film
vous avez décidé de faire une liste des
films que j'avais aimé enfin une liste
de tous les films que j'ai vus mais avec
un petit code couleur disant ce que j'ai
aimé ou pas j'en ai retenu 11
parmi ceux là qui sont les films que
j'ai particulièrement aimé pour des
raisons diverses et variées et le
premier de la liste dans la catégorie
films américains bien
et fait b boys qui est sorti en début
d'année que j'ai énormément aimé et je
vais vous expliquer pourquoi
parce que c'est un film qui qui a l'air
d'être un film policier à la base je
suis pas très friand des films policiers
mais j'ai su aller parce que les était
composée d'acteurs que j'aime bien
ils sont des acteurs talentueux et le
prouve encore une fois dans ce film est
donc c'est une sa part d'une enquête en
gros on pourrait penser puisque c'est
une femme dont la fille a été assassinée
l' enquête n'avance pas le film commence
plusieurs mois après rien ne se passe
faute de preuves faute de piste pour la
police donc elle décide de payer des
panneaux publicitaires l'entrée de la
ville qui accuse le chef de la police en
disant bouge toi le cul et donc ce film
au lieu d'être une bête enquête
policière on chercherait qui est le
coupable est plutôt un film sur les
réactions de chacune des personnes à
cette affaire déjà et au sud qui en sort
donnée par la mère qui ne veut pas que
la police h à faire par les policiers
qui ont chacun leurs points de vue sur
la question par les gens de la ville qui
disent que toute cette peur d'être un
petit peu trop remuer et donc au final
on se désintéresse assez rapidement de
qui a fait ça enfin en tout cas moi
c'était pas ce qui m'intéressait le plus
dans ce film mais on se prend 2 de
compassion pour les personnages jusqu'au
personnage du flic pourri racistes
homophobes qui finalement a plus à
offrir que des trains pourri racistes
homophobes et j'ai vraiment passé un
très bon devant ce film notamment la
scène j'essaierai de passeports et les
danses est dans cette vidéo mais la
scène où le filtre à 6 pourrir mon job
dont j'ai oublié le nom lit une lettre
dans le commissariat
si vous l'avez vu vous savez quelle
synergie et moi j'étais c'était beau
deuxième film dans la catégorie film un
peu onirique italiens comme ibrahim
appelle moi partons donc c'est un film
j'ai oublié le nom du réalisateur mais
vous allez faire des recherches sur
internet et donc c'est un film qui
raconte la jeunesse d'un garçon qui je
sais pas il doit voir 16 17 ans
peut-être dans ce film dans les années
70 en italie donc dans une famille
binaire bien riche je pense plutôt
bourgeoise intellectuelle classes aisées
qui fréquentent les musées les personnes
influentes qui par l'opéra est là donc
ça se passe pendant un été dans cette
maison de vacances italiennes où le
jeune garçon donc
découvre l'amour et notamment son
homosexualité bisexualité d'ailleurs
plutôt bisexualité je pense c'était très
beau c'est c'est un film on se laisse
porter par une ambiance
voilà de vin quand mon assentiment de
regarder une vidéo de vacances qui sont
passés qui ne se reproduiront jamais
plus avec les deux très belle musique
j'écoute encore régulièrement de très
beaux décors et paysages et on se laisse
porter par cette famille qui est quand
même loin d'être une famille ordinaire
et aussi par le personnage dont deux cet
étudiant beaucoup plus âgée que le
personnage principal donc ce qui est une
chose qu'à porter à polémique
apparemment pour le film c'est vrai
qu'il ya un grand écart d'âge entre les
deux mais donc sept étudiants qui
débarquent dans la famille et qui
bouleverse les relations entre les
différents personnages et notamment qui
crée des liens très forts avec eux le
personnage du jeune garçon et lyon que
le procès ait lieu
oui donc voilà on est loin du film
précédent qui était plus film
psychologique sur sur des personnages
qui ont souffert là c'était plus mal à
quelque chose d'assez onirique j'ai
trouvé qui moi m'a fait du bien que j'ai
revu avec plaisir d'ailleurs puisque
jamais revoir les films que j'ai aimé
dans la plupart déçus de cette liste des
films que j'ai vus deux fois mois puis
on pense à me permet d'affirmer mon avis
si j'ai vraiment aimé ou pas si c'était
sur le coup ou pas puisque la plupart du
temps quand je sors du cinéma je suis
assez heureuse et je me dis que c'est le
plus beau film que j'ai vu jusqu'à ce
que je retourne au cinéma et que je sois
à nouveau heureux c'est que je me dise à
nouveau que c'est plus beau film que
j'aie jamais vu donc j'aime bien me
faire un second avis est la même avec 1
se monte à vie j'étais très contente de
ce film troisième film dans la catégorie
ah bah enfin l'homme qui tua donc être
apte au don quichotte pas si vous
connaissez un petit peu l'histoire de ce
film c'était un projet d'airé que terry
gilliam savait depuis très très
longtemps qu'il a eu beaucoup de mal à
sortir jusqu'au dernier le jour avant la
sortie il ya eu des problèmes je sais
plus avec sa maison de production
bref c'était toute une galère et c'est
l'un des films de l'année ce que
d'ailleurs je n'ai pas pu revoir puisque
malheureusement n'est toujours pas sorti
en dvd
je pense encore une fois que ces
problèmes là qu'il a rencontré pour la
production de ce film parce que vu la
date à laquelle il est sorti et devrait
être là prêts à être au pied du sapin
pour la noël mais non je n'ai pas pu le
revoir et j'en suis très déçu mais c'est
un film que j'ai beaucoup aimée parce
qu'il fait écho à un style de film que
j'aime qui est le style de film qui fait
un peu compte conte moderne qui mêle
différentes époques différents univers
moi il m'a beaucoup fait penser à de
folles de tarsem singh qui est l'un de
mes chine préférait que j'adore si vous
ne l'avez pas vu il faut le voir
d'ailleurs il y as ribéry qui a fait une
très belle vidéo dessus après que j'ai
fait découvrir ce film d'ailleurs et à
vous devriez la regarder et non de folle
c'est un film qui mêle différentes
époques les années 20 30 aux indiennes
et d une époque complètement
indéfinissable mais plus ancienne que çà
et là on était un petit peu dans le même
la même état d'esprit puisque l'homme
qui tua don quichotte se passe de nos
jours mais il fait aussi des renvois à
quelques années avant dans la genèse du
réalisateur de radiateur fictif du film
un parent terry gilliam ce et fait aussi
appel à tout un univers ce dos médiéval
fantastique de par les costumes de par
les personnages qui apparaissent donc
c'est un gros mélange un gros bordel de
plein de trucs et c'est ça que j'aime
dans le cinéma et l'autre aspect
intéressant de ce film c'est qu'il était
composé de adam driver et ça c'est un
aspect aussi qui moi me parle
particulièrement
encore une fois j'ai juste un bruit
depuis fois mais aussi parce que
j'adorais suis toujours à jour à sion
et c'était beau je suis pas une très
bonne critique dans le sens où
généralement j'ai pas beaucoup
d'arguments à apporter un film à part
que c'était bien
et l'homme qui tonnent don quichotte
c'était bien voilà que dire d'autre sur
ce film mais il m'a fait rêver voyager
qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre du cinéma
regardez le si vous pouvez puisque moi
je ne peux plus alors s'il faut trouver
un moyen de me regarder
regardez le quatrième film dans la
catégorie
le monde va mal la mauvaise réputation
encore une fois c'est un film que je
n'ai pas pu revoir puisque c'est un film
norvégien aux pakistanais qui est sorti
dans un petit cinéma de l'île et que je
n'ai pas retrouvé depuis
ne serait-ce qu'en dvd ou un autre moyen
souterrain mais c'était vraiment bien
dans mon souvenir
donc c'est un film qui raconte la
jeunesse d'une jeune fille d'origine
pakistanaise qui vit en norvège qui est
élevé de manière plutôt classique qui
vit bien plutôt classique pour une jeune
lycéenne de 500 peut-être environ
jusqu'à ce que ses parents se rendre
compte qu'elle fréquente des garçons
d'un peu trop près notamment je pense en
jouant au foot avec que si mon souvenir
est exact ce qui ne se fait pas ça
rappelle un petit peu joue la comme
beckham dans un registre beaucoup plus
léger et donc là ça part en cacahuète
ah oui non il ya aussi un épisode où
elle reçoit un garçon chez elle la nuit
faites pas ça chez vous voyons et donc
du coup la séparant vire beaucoup plus
extrémistes dans la pratique de leur
religion et décide de la renvoyer au
pays au pakistan dans la famille de son
oncle et sa tante je crois et donc c'est
un petit peu une descente aux enfers
pour elle qui a été élevé
et voilà de manière plutôt sympa et son
père était très affectueux
là tout à coup se retrouve dans une
famille qui est beaucoup moins
sympathique avec elle parce qu'il la
voit un peu comme le vilain petit canard
comme celle qui a qui a fauté et dans un
environnement aussi qui est beaucoup
moins sympa et c'est un peu une descente
aux enfers mais fort heureusement qu'il
n'est pas tout noir ou tout blanc tout
blanc qui seraient les gentils
norvégiens qui ont un mode de vie sympa
et tout loire les méchants musulmans
heureusement ça n'est pas le cas c'est
des personnages comme celui du père sont
assez ambigu et ne propose pas qu'une
vision complètement rétrograde de la
religion musulmane
donc c'était un film vraiment très bien
traités j'ai trouvé très bien joué aussi
interprété notamment par la fille qui
était super bien encore une fois si vous
avez l'occasion de le voir regarder le
jeu ne sait pas quand il sortira s'il
sortira mais en tout cas la mauvaise
réputation c'était vraiment un bon
souvenir pour moi alors peut-être que si
j'avais eu l'occasion de le revoir je
n'aurais pas classée dans les meilleurs
films de l'année
j'en sais rien mais en tout cas moi j'en
ai un très bon souvenir non on va
repartir sur un triptyque de la jeunesse
musulmane de france et de navarre
puisque le film suivant dans la
catégorie jeunes de banlieue s'appelle à
genoux les gars 1
en sortant de ce film j'étais beaucoup
plus partagés divise et surtout pendant
le visionnage de ce film parce que c'est
un film qui aborde des sujets très dur
et on a du mal à situer le point de vue
du réalisateur par rapport à ce qu'est
abordée pendant tout visionnage de films
et jusqu'à la fin où là ça devient un
peu plus clair je me demandais mais mais
qu'est ce qu'il en pense le real est ce
qu est-ce qui cautionnent ça non enfin
il doit pas il faut pas et finalement on
voit que c'est vraiment une dénonciation
lorsqu'est abordée dans le film mais de
manière tellement second degré que que
ça crée une sensation de malaise par
moment c'est vraiment là le film qui dit
on peut rire de tout même du viol est en
fait c'est un film qui aborde notamment
le revenge porn donc qui est le fait de
deux films et des personnes en faisant
des trucs sexuelle et ensuite de leur
faire du chantage par rapport à ça et
donc c'est vraiment ça le propos du film
ce sont deux soeurs de banlieue
strasbourgeoise qui ils fréquentent
chacune un garçon qui sont deux potes et
sa tour de mal il ya énormément d'humour
dans ce film qui a été coécrit par les
de parler par les deux filles d'ailleurs
il me semble qu'ils jouent dedans plus
de real et on sent du coup a vraiment
dans leur manière de parler dans les
expressions quel emploi dans leur humour
on sent cette influence que c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui a été en
partie écrit par des personnes de cet
âge et de cette culture
et ça c'est vraiment bien et du coup il
y avait des passages de montrer très
drôle c'est un peu moi j'ai trouvé très
drôle
si on arrive à s'affranchir du fait
qu'on rit de ces choses là et mais la
fin est plutôt jouissive en termes de
vengeance et c'est un film avec très peu
de budget avec enfin je pense avec une
real qui est pas un faux folle des plans
très long surtout on voit pas ce qu'il
en a fait aussi le web série qu'on
retrouve sur youtube et qui en cours de
diffusion dans l'heure qui fini mais on
prolonge encore plus les plans et je
pense que le film aurait pu durer neuf
heures facile s'ils avaient tous gardé
ans comme beaucoup de films je pense
mais voilà il aime bien faire des plans
l'ont gardé la conversation le plus
longtemps possible avec une partie
d'improvisation même par exemple il ya
un moment où il se balade dans la rue et
on entend quelqu'un dire c'est un
tournage
et l'un des acteurs répond ah ouais
bonne soirée et en fait t'es l'impro
puisque c'est vraiment des gens dans la
rupture montée et vous fait tourner un
film
enfin voila c'était vraiment bien et lui
a priori vous pouvez le revoir vous
pouvez voir la websérie sur youtube qui
est vraiment une version longue du film
en fait et c'était bien en plus il y
avait des images de strasbourg et j'aime
beaucoup strasbourg film suivant
toujours dans cette catégorie jeunesse
de banlieue que j'ai revu récemment
puisque je les revues avant-hier le
monde est à toi de le sais plus son
prénom mais gavras fils de costa gavras
la première fois que j'arrive à citer un
réalisateur dans cette vidéo pourra dans
les rues terry gilliam ceci donc le
monde est à toi cette un film qui
m'avait pas à tirer à la base parce que
j'avais l'impression que c'était un film
sur 10 leur envol yeux ça m'attirait pas
plus que ça et au final on en a parlé en
me disant beaucoup de bien et notamment
que c'était un film aussi sur les
parents abusifs pas dans le sens où il
amusé de manière totalement illégale de
leurs enfants
mais dans le sens où il essaye de
contrôler leur vie et c'était vraiment
ça avec le personnage d'isabelle adjani
adjani était juste génial et son fils un
neveu relations entre elle et son fils
était super bien traités notamment quand
ya un parallèle entre ça et la relation
de d'une jeune écossaise avec son père
aussi vous verrez dans le film ce qu'il
faut voir c'est vraiment un de mes
préférés de l'année
ouais un ton un peu décalée avec les
mentions des illuminati avec le
personnage de poutine qui est
complètement tordus et bizarre pas
vladimir
un mec qui s'appelle poutine et c'était
bien
non vraiment c'est pas juste un film de
dire c'est un film qui traite vraiment
des gens parlent des gens
le monde est à toi bonjour c'est jeanne
moreau nouveau film dans la catégorie le
racisme est partout black clouds man ou
comme j'aime l'appeler black avec
klinsmann et je pense que là c'est
vraiment mon film préféré de l'année
c'était génial c'était c'était beau
c'était puissant donc c'est un film sur
si vous n'avez pas suivi sur un policier
noir qui arrive à infiltrer le ku klux
klan et s'est tiré d'une histoire vraie
et forcément elle inquiète rue par des
moyens détournés parce qu'il peut pas
juste pointer en étant noir et en disant
bonjour je déteste les noirs ça ne se
fait pas il y avait atteint driver dans
ce film et je passerai très vite sur
cette information parce que ça n'est pas
l'information principale la formation
principale c'est que c'est un film
important qu'il faut voir et c'était
vraiment très bien du début à la fin
puisque déjà c'est très bien mené très
bien joué et jusqu'au bout on a
l'impression de partir sur un happy end
en ch'ti cendres ouais ça va ils ont
résolu leur problème
et puis le film nous balance à la gueule
aussi que ce racisme cette
ces temps-ci antisémitisme aussi puisque
c'est aussi un sujet abordé dans le film
cette haine est belle existe encore de
nos jours et ça le film nous le rappelle
très bien
on n'est pas dans une optique ah bah ça
va parce que depuis on a bien évolué non
on n'a pas tant que ça évolue
et justement j'avais une conversation de
là dessus avec un pote en parlant de dr
who puisqu'on avait parlé des épisodes
sur rosa parks qui est très bien donc un
jeu passe d'un sujet à l'autre mais dans
la dernière saison doctoraux égard un
épisode sur rosa parks que j'ai beaucoup
aimé mais c'est vrai qu'à un moment il
ya une réplique au lard et personnages
dit mais depuis on a voté obama
ouais c'est cool mais après c'est il ya
une preuve donc non tu peux pas juste
résumer la fin du racisme a eu au pas et
donc plateau lansman me rappelle très
bien que leur incident est partout tout
le temps de nos jours aussi
et donc c'est un film qu'il est
important de voir et je pense que c'est
le grand gagnant de cette année pour moi
le film suivant n'a rien à voir puisque
on passe dans la catégorie du viiie
siècle
mademoiselle de jean-pierre mais j'ai
adoré parce que encore une fois concert
film que j'ai pu voir qu'une seule fois
mais c'était un film avec edouard baer
déjà ce qui est un argument en soi et
aussi à 10,6 à ce que j'aime beaucoup et
il y avait cécile de france qui en plus
d'être non de monible est une actrice
que j'aime bien donc c'est un fille sur
les trahison amoureuse au xviiie siècle
très les liaisons dangereuses
il ya des gens qui ont dit ah c'est une
parodie c'est une mauvaise réplique des
missions dangereuses mais non c'est
juste un autre film donc sur cécile de
france qui se fait trahir par edouard
baer qui est qui est une sorte de don
jouan qui séduit tout le monde et elle
décide de se venger et c'est tellement
bien mené avec des dialogues qui sont
savoureux parce que je trouve qu'il
parle très bien le français 18e un peu
perché et il ya surtout une scène de
edouard baer qui se retrouvent dans un
quiproquo ils se retrouvent
et avec cécile de france qui veut se
venger de lui et avec les deux
personnages dont la fille qu'il veut
séduire qui fait partie de la vengeance
mais lui c'est pas lui c'est rien il
comprend rien à ce qui se passe et ils
s'embrouillent complètement dans la
conversation qui en plus super bien
filmé avec des chandelles enfin
l'éclairage est super beau et on s'était
trop bien c'était bien regarder le
mademoiselle de jonquière le film
suivant est beaucoup moins jolie puisque
c'est un documentaire dans la catégorie
documentaire on va tous crever le temps
des forêts et donc le vus au cinéma
en plus je sais qu'il y beaucoup de
projections aussi un petit peu partout
accompagné de discussions après le film
là moi je les ai vus dans un ciné mais
il y avait une petite expo à la sortie
sur les forêts c'est donc c'est un film
qui nous parle des forêts de nos jours
et je les ai vu juste avant de sortir
mon épisode de chroniques de profs sur
les forêts à travers les époques et ça
m'a beaucoup apporté parce que il
explique surtout que dans la
reforestation
c'est pas bien c'est pas forcément bien
et ça c'est quelque chose que j'ignorais
donc il nous parle de l'état des forêts
françaises qui sont dans un mauvais état
je vais pas vous spoiler plus que ça
enfin non le justement je peux vous
spoiler ça pas mal et donc il nous
montre là tous les problèmes qui sont
liés à la monoculture au fait que les
sols sont complètement appauvri et il
est très bien réalisé un très bon sens
dans le documentaire mais c'est pour moi
un documentaire à voir et je le place
dans la catégorie des films de l'année
puisque je les lui aussi les regards des
jeux et à défaut regarde les vidéos sur
des forêts regardez plutôt un
documentaire le film suivant c'est dans
la catégorie coupant la tête des gens un
peuple et son roi
je sais qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qu'ils
n'ont pas aimé notamment des historiens
et je sais que je dis aussi beaucoup
notamment dans cette vidéo mais
je me fous un peu d des inexactitudes
historiques
quand je vais voir un film j'ai fait
pour voir un film et même si c'est un
film historique
j'y vais pour passer un bon moment pour
pas juste me détendre puneet vider la
tête hein c'est pas ça que j'entends par
passer un bon moment
mais pour apprécier l'oeuvre
cinématographique et pour moi elle n'a
pas besoin d'être juste historiquement
donc moi je m'en fous que la bastille
soient prises sous un grand soleil
alors qu'en vrai il pleuvait ça c'est
vraiment cadet de mes soucis et moi un
peuple et son roi c'est un film qui que
j'ai trouvé très beau visuellement très
bien joué aussi portait pas plein
d'acteurs lot et garonne en robespierre
c'était beau et il y avait un jeu sur
les couleurs jeux sur sur les chansons
aussi il y avait des emplois des
chansons révolutionnaires qui était
vraiment très bien choisi
les costumes les décors je vais partir
en commentaire fans de coach si ça
continue mais vraiment j'ai passé un bon
moment en plus j'ai eu la chance de le
voir en avant première dont les acteurs
ont juste descoings la fin mais moi
c'était toujours cool deux fois en avant
première c'était la cause du peuple et
son dos parce que je rappelle que j'ai
revu mon tout ça fait que j'ai vraiment
passé un moment et je les revues donc je
suis allé voir deux fois au ciné et à
chaque fois c'était génial je dois même
dire que j'ai préféré la deuxième fois
et dont faudrait que je revoie un jour
quand il sera dispo mais c'est vraiment
un film que je revois avec plaisir qui
nous montre une révolution française sur
la continuité de révolution française
qui est beaucoup axé sur le peuple et
non pas sur les dirigeants mais qui
aussi reprend des passages entiers de
deux débats à l'assemblée qu'ils sont
vieux aussi un peu du point de vue du
peuple puisque on voit que la population
avait accès aux débats à l'assemblée par
eux par une
une estrade où il pouvait se tenir value
stran est par exemple le discours de
robespierre les discours puisqu'ils
s'expriment plusieurs fois sont des
vrais discours qu'il a tenu en version
très abrégé bien sûr puisqu'il pouvait
parler pendant des heures
et ça on voit bien puisque un discours
qui commence deux jours et qui se
terminent de nuit
mais tout ça est vraiment fidèle donc si
en plus vous aimez les troupes fidèles
my hand a pas que ça mais il y en a qu
un peuple et son roi c'était vraiment
très très bien ma voix commencent à
vraiment à partir en cacahuète donc on
va accélérer il reste deux films dans la
catégorie on est tous dépressif mais ça
va legrand bat le grand vin c'était donc
un film de gilles lellouche film
français mais vous pourrez y en a
plusieurs dans cette dans cette
sélection toute manière mais je ne suis
pas de ces gens qui disent que les films
français sont tous pourris jeux tels que
cap adams le grand bain c'était un film
qui est une comédie où l'on rit vraiment
beaucoup par moments mais qui a un fond
de tout le monde va mal en fait tous les
personnages sont plus ou moins des
précédents films et se retrouve
justement se rejoignent dans cet état de
mal être et essaye d'en faire quelque
chose de positif par la natation
synchronisée puisque pourquoi pas ça
peut être n'importe quoi et mutuellement
du coup il arrive à s'en sortir à leur
niveau 1 c'est pas le film se termine
pas en or d'un coup tout le monde va
mieux tout le monde est heureux sont pas
remporté un grand truc et comme ils le
disent à la fin ils attendent une
reconnaissance qui ne viendra jamais
parce que tout le monde s'en fout qu'ils
aient gagné un prix de natation
synchronisée
mais eux ça leur a permis à un moment où
l'avait un peu la tête du trou et de
s'en sortir et c'est ça qui est beau
dans ce film je pense que je vais
arrêter
cette description livre en main et 6 1
plongez le voir le pain le dernier film
que j'ai choisi pour cette vidéo c'est
dans la brume
encore un film français dit et lui il
est sorti il ya plus longtemps mais je
l'avais pas vu je l'aï vu récemment dans
une tentative de rattraper tous les
films sortis en 2010 gîte mais que je
n'avais pas vu au ciné et donc dans la
bohème c'est un film de science fiction
française qui est plutôt rare et que
j'ai trouvé vraiment bien il est assez
court et justement du coup il ya pas
vraiment amber enfin tout est utilisé
intelligemment
bon il ya des influences il ya des
incohérences dans le scénario parce qu'à
des moments je me suis dit mais vous
faites pas ça il ya des maladresses mais
vraiment il va plonger dans une ambiance
que j'ai beaucoup apprécié l'ambiance un
peu votre site à pau qui vous tombe
dessus d'un coup donc c'est un film ou
d'un coup il ya une brume qui s'élève
dans paris et probablement dans toute la
france peut-être mon entière ne s'est
pas et qui tue l'amour qu'ils tuent et
donc qu'ils essayent de s'en sortir en
montant vers les toits donc si vous avez
une chambre de bonne à paris c'est cool
vous survivez est par contre le problème
c'est qu'ils ont une fille qui a un
maladies qui n'existent pas deux jours
il me semble t il c'est une maladie qui
l'a fait qu'elle doit vivre enfermé dans
une sorte de bulle protectrice
donc c'est ça qui nous rappelle aussi
que le film se passe dans un futur assez
proche puisqu'il il ya quand même
certains éléments de modernité qu'on n'a
pas et notamment cette bulle et elle par
contre du coup elle est obligée de
rester au milieu de la brume dans sa
bulle
mais dont la batterie faiblit c'est tout
ça pose le problème de risques on va la
sauver
et donc c'était bien je pense qu'on peut
terminer on peut conclure comme on a
commencé en disant que les films c'était
bien j'aurais pu parler d'autres films
par exemple il ya des films que j'ai pas
vu et que je voulais voir que je verrai
probablement on a beaucoup parlé des
garçons sauvages
je regarde un peu par là parce que c'est
là qu'ils hamon qui ava liste de films
c'est pas juste que je vous aime pas on
va beaucoup parler des garçons sauvages
et il faut que je le vois pas ce qu'on
on m'a dit que c'était vraiment très
bien mais à d'autres films que j'avais
envie de voir par exemple wonder wins
venom une puisse enfin avec c'était bien
dogma ne sais pas ça mathivet et à des
films qui ne sont pas encore sortis
aussi et que j'ai envie de voir ou alors
qu'ils sont sortis et que j'ai pas
encore pu voir comme spider man show à
la shlmr où l'empereur de paris qui
m'attire aussi le retour de mary poppins
voilà ces films-là m'attire mais je n'ai
pas encore pu les voir il ya aussi des
films que j'ai détesté les films que
j'ai un peu aimée mais moins que ceux
dont je vous ai parlé donc là en
générique je vais vous mettre liste des
films que j'ai aimé que j'ai pas aimé
que j'ai aimé mais pas trop et j'espère
que cette vidéo vous a plu malgré
probablement le manque d'entrain lié au
fait qu' il ya encore deux jours j'étais
est allé dans un canapé sans oser bouger
parce que j'étais souffrante et aussi
des au fait que ma voix s'est détérioré
de plus en plus en cours de vidéo mais
j'avais envie de faire ce petit hors
série cinéma si ça vous plaît je
pourrais vous parler de cinéma de temps
en temps ça va vraiment pas devenir un
truc récurrent parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de gens qui parlent beaucoup mieux de
cinéma que moi mais c'est vraiment
quelque chose que j'adore je vais au
cinéma au moins une fois par semaine je
regarde jouer nous vous les films tout
le temps et et surtout en ce moment je
suis vraiment du goût les métiers
aujourd'hui dans ce quartier tout le
temps et de découvrir des trucs que je
connais pas et donc voilà je vous
souhaite de bonnes fêtes de fin d'année
et je ne sais pas pourquoi je prends
cette action mais à bientôt
et comme comme le dit le très célèbre
personnage ne pouvait bien drap se dit
que j allais pas cité mais que j'ai
beaucoup aimé le show
vasco abl m'hamed
mais je n'ai vraiment plus le voir
j'ai totalement oublié alors je vous
fais ça rapidement
c'est bien ça occupera génériques je
voulais aussi vous parler de time warp
puisque vous je me suis dit on parle de
cinéma donc parlant de série donc
parlons du web série dans parlons de
marc webb série et donc je sais que je
pas beaucoup de données de nouvelle là
dessus parce que c'est toujours en cours
et donc le voilà c'est ce que je voulais
vous dire c'est toujours en cours on ne
sait pas marre et aux bahamas avec
l'argent donc c'est pas moi qui gère la
postproduction je fais vraiment plus
rien depuis le tournage dessus puisque
c'est quelqu'un d'autre qui gère le
montage mixage truste tous ces trucs là
sachez que le dernier épisode termine
d'être montée on sur les six épisodes de
la série et que bien sûr ça n'est pas la
fin puisque il ya la composition de la
musique aussi qui est en cours deux
premiers épisodes sont composés me
semble oui les deux premiers mais après
il restera les effets spéciaux
l'étalonnage de mixage le générique
affaires se voir bla bla bla donc on en
a encore pour quelques mois
mais sachez que ça avance et de toute
façon je vous tiendrai au courant
puisque je moi je ferai la promotion une
fois que ça sera pas loin d'être prêt à
sortir
donc je vous ferai les bandes-annonces
d'heures qu'il n'ait pas fait non plus
la bande annonce donc encore un truc à
faire avant de sortir la vidéo absorber
la série donc moi je vous tiendrai au
courant de tout ça et je vous sortirait
des petits teasers pour vous donner
envie de regarder
en tout cas moi ce que je vois arriver
quand on m'envoie des trucs me fait très
plaisir donc j'espère que vous aimerez
et en revoir
[Musique]